hey what's up my name's samuel lee's
right now i am reading your comments on
my youtube channel you know what i'm
doing i'm responding in this video i'm
responding to your comments your
questions your challenges so if you are
a subscriber of the channel then comment
below anything that's been bothering you
that's hindered you that you're
struggling with in the property
investment space comment below and i'll
help you fix that problem right here
right now on this week's q a sunday if
you're not subscribed to the channel
subscribe turn the notification bell on
and then comment your questions or
problems below and i'll do my best to
help you too and if you enjoy my content
if you enjoy my channel i put out a
video every single day to help and serve
my subscribers so if you enjoy that
hit the like button i look forward to
reading your questions let's see what
our questions we had from last week so
we've got
samuel you often say you prefer not to
buy properties through a deal saucer but
what do you say when it comes to an
overseas investor from holland like me
who wants to invest in the uk
okay a few things i'll say
he'd come in um first thing i'll say
that means i love you in dutch i love
you bro thanks for watching my channel
um
i wouldn't rule out investing in the
netherlands
don't feel like just because you're
watching me in the uk doing deals in the
uk that you have to invest in the uk too
because there's so many opportunities
all across the planet where there's
really really really good returns to be
made so i want to rule out holland
if you do want to invest in the uk
though and if you really set on it
i don't tell people not to buy through a
deal sorcerer that would be crazy
because i am a deal saucer and i teach
people to be deal sources so if i said
never buy from a deal sorcerer that
would kind of be a strange thing to say
but you're right what i do say is i say
um
be careful buying from a deal saucer
because there's a lot of deal sources
out there who will make something look
better than it is um or more importantly
there's deal sources out there that
don't know what they're doing and
they're selling deals
that aren't even good deals so if you if
you're paying somebody to package and
sell you an investment deal you need as
the investor to take responsibility and
to know whether it's a good deal
yourself or not so if you're living in
holland
by all means pay a deal sorcerer in
england but make sure that you are
educated as to what a good deal is so
you know the right questions to ask and
you can check for any flags and put a
really good power team together as well
in the uk there are people in the uk
that you could work with that could find
you deals they could manage the process
but make sure you're not just paying
people blindly
and being ignorant make sure you know
what you're doing yourself so no one can
pull the wall over your eyes i hope that
helps i hope to see you do well
next rasman gabriel says would you buy a
house that's next to a railway
i'm worried about the capital
appreciation of this house house is in
manchester nine minutes to the city
center house would cash flow positive
i'd really appreciate your opinion on
this all right razvan
if the house is next to railway i assume
it's really close because if it's like a
five minute walk away that's a good
thing because it's convenient i assume
you mean it's next to a railway and you
can hear
the trains and the station and it's
noisy um so my advice is if you're
planning on buying the property to do it
up and to sell it to a family and flip
it
it would put me off if there was like a
really noisy
uh station literally within a hundred
meters away um the reason it would put
me off is because it might put some
future buyers off as well
um
i would probably speak to estate agents
in the area and get their input and it
would it's really hard for me to say
without knowing exactly how close we're
talking are we talking 20 meters are we
talking 120 meters are we talking 250
meters how noisy is it um
some people don't mind i remember when i
was looking for a house to live in i was
looking around richmond in london and
every 30 seconds there was planes i just
couldn't stand there i was like i can't
live here but then the the the locals
were like what's your problem we just
spent three million pounds on the house
here it doesn't bother us so i'd
probably speak to the estate agents and
say look is this street gonna be
particularly bad is it gonna be
particularly noisy they'll be able to
tell you what most uh buyers would think
wish you all the very best make sure it
does cash flow positive that's the most
important thing all right next oscar
i'm 24. me and my fiance are looking to
buy a house or a flat with about 10 to
15 000 pounds of cash
we are not sure which mortgage to take
and for how long we're looking to live
in it for a few years then maybe flip it
rent it out and upgrade to a bigger
place what do you suggest ps we're about
to have a baby ah well firstly
congratulations
one of them the second most beautiful
thing in the world is having a baby the
first is finding the right partner to be
with to have the baby and the third
thing is becoming rich and becoming a
multi-millionaire business person um so
congratulations in terms of mortgage if
you've got 10 15 grand you want to live
in it you're going to want to just get a
residential mortgage ideally on a
first-time buyer you can get up to 95
depends on your earnings and your credit
but i would get a residential mortgage
most mortgage lenders will fix you in
for two years
you want to live in it for a few years
anyway forget a residential mortgage
live in it for a couple few years
then if it's gone up in value and you
want to refinance it we've financed it
on a buy to let mortgage hopefully once
the value's gone up a little bit or
you've pushed the value up so i think
it's quite straightforward but massive
congratulations on the baby i'm really
really excited about that baby coming
and uh good luck
roma j when you refinance the house
let's say you choose to reinvest the
money do you still keep the property
even though you've pulled all your money
out and invested
yes
of course you refinance the house
you keep the house and then you use the
money
to reinvest yeah absolutely
don king
samuel
why does planning permission take so
long
and what's the realistic time it should
take and what could be done to speed up
the process if it's taking longer and
longer than expected cheers don king
i feel you paying brother i really
really do
getting planning permission can take
years it is no joke even if it's
something really simple i'm having
issues myself with several sites um i
used to secure
lease option agreements on properties or
pieces of land and i used to have
a 12 to 18 month period of where i would
tell them i'd get the planning to push
the now i'm saying like 24 36 like it
literally can take forever uh how do you
speed it up get a planning get a good
planning consultant
make sure that when you put in the
application initially make sure that you
put it in well you put it in right
make sure that you answer all their
questions quickly and properly uh
because they're going to ask you a bunch
of questions about a bunch of stuff and
you need to respond well initially make
sure that you are friends with the
neighbours
because if you get more than five people
objecting in the area it will then have
to go to committee and it can take
longer but more importantly be patient
it's all part of the process when you're
putting in planning applications um if
if the deal's right and if you're gonna
make as much profit as i'm making on my
deals i'm happy to sit out and wait and
just factor in expect it to take longer
than it should the councils are slow um
and at the moment
they are dragging on so i hope that
helps and i really hope that you get the
application accepted soon my brother all
right next russell pectory
the banks have rumored they're going to
increase interest rates okay firstly
when the banks rumor stuff i never
listen or pay attention because often
what about all the rumors that were
going around last year they're going to
increase capital gains tax it could
double and i was just saying everybody
chill and then when the um when the
financial statements everything came out
of the budget uh what happened nothing
so there's often a lot of scaremongering
that goes on right let me let me finish
your question and then i'll maybe go on
a small rant
within something increasing by inflation
by three percent house prices an
all-time high does this mean a recession
looming or could i would i mean a
recession looming man we just had a
recession damn or should i hang fire and
wait for house prices to drop then go
for it love watching and learning listen
bro i appreciate your support um
i don't think interest rates are gonna
go up by three percent i really really
don't the reason here's why
if they were about to put interest rates
up by three percent the banks would not
be letting people fix their interest
rates for up to 10 years
which they are
if you're worried about interest rates
going up dude then fix the interest
rates
the only thing that seems to be going up
right now at the moment is house prices
and rents and i predicted this two years
ago i was saying what's going up folks
interest rates house prices or rents
everyone's on interest rates oh and i
said no interest rates aren't going
anywhere house prices are going up and
rents are going up i predict you can
watch about my old videos i've been
doing videos now for five six years
fix the interest rates
net if you keep waiting never the
perfect time when house brushes are
going up whoa
you're like oh
whereas if they stop falling soon
and then when they start falling oh
they're falling like
just don't wait to buy houses buy houses
and wait bang that's a good quote i
didn't make it up but it's a good quote
make sure it's cash flow and positive it
doesn't even matter
just buy buy it right in the right area
get the right brand and stop being a
[ __ ] that's my best advice and i know
you're not being a [ __ ] totally you're
trying to do due diligence and you're
trying to make sure you're making the
right decision and everything like that
but when you buy right it doesn't matter
when you buy you can make money when
houses are going up you can make money
when houses are going down i have the
authority to say this because i was
buying in 2009.
do you know how crazy scared everyone
was in 2009 i've been through recessions
i've been through two recessions now so
i kind of feel like i have the authority
to say that all right brandon and one
more thing i'll say every investment
comes with risk
every investment
if you want zero risk you don't want any
risk at all then don't ever leave your
house because you could get hit by a car
stay in your bedroom but even then
you'll have risk because you're not
getting vitamin d like
like life is risky
no one's gonna make it alive
everyone's gonna die
so
i i try and just look at the worst case
scenario the best case scenario and say
okay i need to make an executive
decision right now you know all right um
brandon smith love your videos
appreciate it joining your 12 hour zoom
calls
legit sometimes i run 12 hour zoom
course i'm a crazy dude no one runs 12
hours zoom course apart from me i was
just wondering what the term refinancing
means i hear it a lot and doesn't really
make sense could you explain it in
detail so i fully understand refinance
means getting a new loan okay so
if you buy a house
and then you buy you buy with a mortgage
bridging finance whatever
if you then try and take out another
loan against the existing loan you're
refinancing again getting new finance
and then the new finance will pay off
the old finance
might be a better rate
different type of loan so what you often
do is you buy a house get a bridging
loan push the value up and then get a
new loan against the new value and then
with that new loan pay off the bridge
inc and you're left with a free house so
that's usually when i use the term i
hope that makes sense if it doesn't
comment again keep telling me keep
commenting again and again until you
understand you need to understand this
otherwise you're not going to win and
you need i want to see you win
reuben's life
what months do you find the properties
are the cheapest and what's the best way
to source them
best way to solve properties and where
are they the cheapest i personally like
buying houses best in the month of
december
you know why because in december
everybody is chilling out and winding
down for christmas because they're all
[ __ ]
oh i'm getting cozy for christmas right
they're all getting cozy for christmas
meanwhile i'm out there working so my
investors all my competition
are at home with their loved ones
enjoying the winter right in december
winding down like a [ __ ] what am i
doing i'm out working hard next
when it gets close to christmas
sellers are scared
because a lot of sellers they put the
house on october november and they're
thinking i need to sell before christmas
they don't want this house out to drag
on into the new year
so if you start pushing in december
and get people mid-december when
everyone else is winding down you should
be winding up and the sellers are
getting scared because they're scared
that their house i was going to drag
onto the next year
they're like i did not want this house
going on into 2022. i just want to get
it off my off my mind i don't want to go
into a new year with this old house that
i'm trying to sell so you've got
motivated sellers
wimpy ass buyers
you come and dominate that's my best
month and what's the best way to source
them
um speak to estate agents speak to
estate agents and get in with estate
agents to become friends with estate
agents and know what to say to your
stations all right emily yip says i've
decided to change my strategy in deal
sourcing and sell rent to rent deals
instead of brr i've completed the rent
to rent and the dsm training and i'm
looking for my first deal my question is
how do i negotiate a rental rent deal
before knowing what the investors
intentions are
all right if you're doing rent to rent
deal sourcing be careful it's the
hardest kind of deal source in there it
is because
if you package a buy to let it's really
clear the investors just like i know
what i'm getting
if you package your brr deal it's quite
clear straightforward right
rent to rent
rent to rent
rent rent a business
it's not a property investment if you
package a rent to rent you're not
packaging a property investment and
selling it you're packaging a business
opportunity
if you sell a business up to someone who
is not a business person and they just
think i'm going to buy a rent to rent
and i'm going to be financially free
they'll buy your rent to rent believe me
you'll have no problem selling it but
you'll sell it to some dum dum that
won't know how to run it because they've
not been trained and educated the
expectations were all wrong they'll mess
the rent to rent up the keys will go
back to the landlord and then you'll be
like oh and then the investor will be
annoyed with you
i want a refund it didn't work you're
right
it worked you didn't work because you
messed it up so i've seen a lot of
problems with packaging and selling
rental rents the solution would be if
you're selling a rent to rent make sure
you're selling it to someone that's
already in the business and already in
the space
and they've got a business that's
already doing it and they're paying you
because it's a good deal rather than
paying you to just make them financially
free because it's a you know be careful
but man you're an awesome person emily
and if you need any help just drop me a
message and i appreciate you okay all
right next
kyle miller
what would you say
what would your script say to an estate
agent looking for a rent to rent deal my
script took if i'm looking for internal
i i would probably ring up
if i rank if it depends there's two ways
to get a wrench idea from an agent
number one is to ring up about a
specific property
number two is to go into the estate
agents in person and pitch them on your
concept
if i'm ringing up a particular property
i'll just ring about the particular
property and i'll just say hey i'm not
going to be living in the house myself
it was going to be a company let but i'm
really interested when could i look
around
that's it i'm just telling them it's a
company that i'm not making a big deal
about it and i'm booking a viewing and
then on the viewing
i'll pitch them on the concept if i'm
walking in to picture on the concept i'm
going to go in with confidence and i'm
going to say to them hey i'm looking to
talk to the person in charge of the
lettings i'm going to sit down and i'm
just going to literally put my cards on
the table hey i'm looking for
landlords i'm looking to rent on a
long-term basis it'll be a company let
and i'll be putting people on short
stays is that concept that you're
familiar with excellent have you got any
landlords that are looking for a
long-term let i'd love to work together
confidence
confidence is key
all right alan partridge when you say
property millionaire do you mean someone
who has a property worth a million
pounds even if it has a mortgage which
is has 75 left on the total price so
really the person is only worth 250 000
not a million pounds
um alan correct so a property
millionaire is not necessarily a
millionaire
a millionaire if you're a millionaire
like i'm a millionaire okay millionaire
means
my net worth after all my expenses all
my debts
my profit that i'm worth is a million
pounds or more i'm a millionaire a
property millionaire means you have a
portfolio of properties and the
properties are valued at a million or
more now you might have lots of
mortgages so your net worth might be
less than a million but
in a way it's kind of just a definition
which you can put your own most people
that say that they're property
millionaires may not be millionaires um
but if you are a property millionaire
and you'd be comfortable just saying
i've got a net worth of 250 just say
you've got a net worth of 250. you know
it's whatever really but yeah property
millionaire is not necessarily a
millionaire hope that makes sense i am
both i'm property minor i'm a
millionaire and i'm a multi-millionaire
cash so
i mean i don't know if if you're just
kind of like curious if you're wondering
about me or whatever but i hope that
makes sense peace out my brother
all right ah mendola love loving getting
through these questions if i answer a
question and there's an offshoot to a
question like that that makes me wonder
about this just go ahead and comment
okay the more questions i get the better
the more excited i get ah mandela says i
like you very much however i think that
you didn't answer a question with an
honest heart oh it sounds like a
critique let's see what you got to say
you sell your courses at over 12 000
pounds each
you would only have to sell 86 courses
to make a total of one million and
thirty two thousand pounds you've sold
hundreds if not thousands forget
property lol trained me how to be a
mentor
is a serious question okay i'll i will
i'll ask you a question and firstly
forget probably teach me how to be a
mentor um
property is way more profitable than
being a trainer or a mentor like way
more if you go on the sunday times rich
list you look at all the millionaires or
the multi-millionaires how many of them
are property trainers none i don't see
any of them being property trainers they
are all
in property they either made their money
in property or they made it in business
and now they're investing in property so
i don't think if you want to be a
multi-millionaire i don't think you're
training there's a way to go about it um
in terms of me myself i didn't start
training i never ran a training company
until i was already a millionaire not
property millionaire a cash millionaire
which i did through packaging and
selling deals through buying and
refinancing properties which you've done
for many years
um
so that's kind of like my answer in
terms of you doing the numbers you only
just like you sell your courses at over
12 000 pounds
no that's not really true
my courses are my advanced courses uh
are 995 and the in-person versions are
195. if you do all of my courses
together and you join the full academy
then that is 12 000 pounds but that
isn't profit i mean
if someone joins the academy i've then
got to spend an entire year looking
after them
mentoring them
provide i take them out for dinners
i have a lot of staff hotels that's not
profit um so i don't know
i mean listen i think it sounds to me
like uh you probably just need to focus
on property for a bit also i really
believe it's unethical to teach property
unless you've been in it for five years
if you haven't done it successfully
yourself you shouldn't be teaching it so
if and if you want to become a mentor to
become rich
you have a wrong heart i mean
i was in i was i started my training
company i've been i was training for
four years before my training for the
first four years
every year my training company made a
loss
so anyone that gets into being a mentor
or whatever for the money is in it for
the wrong reasons anyway um if you
happen to make money because you're
really good at it
but the reason is mission and helping
people then cool but anyway i can speak
all day about that i hope that helps
though our mandela and i hope that
you've changed your mind about wanting
to be a mentor and wanting to be in
property instead because property is
where it's at
all right last question
samuel this is from mega man samuel what
happens if there's a market crash and
prices go down and you have negative
equity on your portfolio i don't care i
really don't give a monkeys because if
the market crashes and my properties go
down and i'm in negative equity
i'm not planning on selling those houses
anyway as long as i'm renting them out
i'm still getting my cash flow i know
that they'll always bounce back up
because properties always do property
prices go up down
up down you don't know exactly how much
they're going to go up by you don't know
exactly how much they're going to go
down by what you do know is that over
time they go up over time so as long as
you sit on it and hold it and it's cash
flowing positive and it's giving you
some passive income you are all good i
hope that helps
guys i hope you find this video helpful
if you did hit the like button i'd love
to read your comments bang them below
and i'll see you guys next time peace